[موسيقى]
لولادين القصور مسجله باسم الوالد
كان ما يحتاج اني اطلع بالعربيه واقول
عندنا قصور باسم الرئيس صدام حسين كان
اتسابقوا ان يعرضون املاك الوالد الوالد
ولا متر بارض العراق مو بس هاي قصور
الدوله مثلها مثل اي دوله ثريه بالعالم
كل الدول الثريه بالعالم بها قصور لكن
القصور كلها اسم الديوان تابعه للدوله مو
باسم الرئيس
[موسيقى]
والاسلحه اللي ذكرتها حضرتك هاي مو للقتال
مو اللي جبهات القتال هاي يصنعها تصنيع
العسكري اولا هي مو مستورده ومو كلفه
خياليه مثل ما تعتقدون هي تصنيع عراقي
مطليه بالذهب اصبح الان يضع الطلاء بالذهب
على الاكل في بعض المطاعم صح صحيح ما اقصد
المطاعم الغاليه والمستثنات بالله صرنا
نشوفها بالسوشال ميديا وكل مكان وهذه
هدايا لرموز لاشخاص يعني ناس معينين
[موسيقى]